I think the most important thing for me
is not whether Thomas kubs deemed to be
guilty or not and clearly they weren't
it's actually the way they've had worse
situation from humanity in a compassion
point of view and really some examples
of that are they don't doesn't appear to
have been a great deal of communication
directly from the company to the parents
of this we had a situation last week
where we went through the inquest in
Wakefield number of senior executives at
Thomas Cook repeatedly said you know
that they weren't in position to answer
anything for all of the questions
so it was no comment and I understand
legally why they were advised to do that
but in my opinion it should have been
balanced with actually more expression
outward expression of compassion for
what actually happened so that's a
explanation for the way in which they
acted if they were fearful of any
further mitigation absolutely absolutely
and I think that they were coached or
advised by the legal team that they
should not put them in selves in a
position where they could say something
that might attract the view that
somebody could seek redress against them
and I think that's why they acted the
way they did that would be my personal
opinion and and I think that even if
they were coached accordingly you get to
a point in an organization particularly
the senior level where you have to
balance what is legally right and
looking after the interests of the
company and shareholders with what is
also the right thing to do with regard
to the people who have been involved in
such a tragic accident
because looking at what they did is you
say they were exonerated in a quarter
worriz the inquest jury however did say
that they'd failed in their duty of care
and after that inquest jury they
apologized the family for all they'd
gone through I think that was the phrase
that they used and they donated some of
the compensation money that they'd
received orbit the entire money they say
to UNICEF so what more do you think they
could have done well there are a number
of things firstly the communication
about the apology was in my opinion far
too late they did apologize but I think
that should have happened a great deal
earlier there was no reason why they
couldn't have offered apologies much
earlier
despite the caution about the
a legal position I think it was very
laudable to donate a one and a half
million pounds for you and a serf it's a
great charity however in my opinion I I
felt that it would be much more
beneficial if they engage with the
family and said we are prepared to
donate one and a half million pounds to
charity do you have any thoughts about
with charity we should donate the money
to or maybe even set up a charity in
sort of commemoration and memory of the
children which is what's happened before
do you think the way they've handled
this could affect their business looking
ahead
well short-term obviously we've seen
some depression in the share price and
we've seen other anecdotal evidence that
evidence that people are not looking at
their site quite as much as they were
and so on but I think the important
thing here is that it's you know that
this particular incidence is a long way
down the track now I think the chief
executive of Thomas Cassell has the
opportunity to come out more openly and
more I suppose more candidly express
their cut sorrow for what it actually
happened for this and I think more
importantly looking forward I think
there are lessons to be learned not just
for Thomas go for any company the phases
of this sort of situation you know my
experience is that when these things
happen and they do happen not frequently
but when they do happen it's quite
important for senior management the
organization to be at the forefront they
should be there at scene where that's
practical where the incidents actually
occurred they should certainly engage
with the people who've been directly
affected with it families relatives and
and so on and they should be very open
with the media about the situation